[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy el caos que viven las
regiones del Perú llegó a Lima miles de
personas marcharon hasta la capital para
mostrar su apoyo a Pedro Castillo pedir
la renuncia de Dina boluarte la
disolución del Congreso y elecciones
anticipadas una semana más de más de un
mes de protestas que han terminado en
violentos enfrentamientos y dejan un
saldo de más de 50 muertos y hay tensión
entre Colombia y Guatemala el fiscal
Rafael curruchiche pidió investigar a
Iván Velázquez actual ministro de
defensa de Colombia por supuesta
corrupción cuando dirigía la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en
Guatemala Estados Unidos respaldó al
funcionario colombiano y anunció que El
guatemalteco está en la lista de
corrupción de la Unión Americana
y el mandatario de Estados Unidos cumple
tres años en el poder con sólo uno
restante de este primer mandato Joe
biden enfrenta el reto del control
republicano en la cámara de
representantes aun con la incógnita de
si se presentará a la reelección y su
edad Como telón de fondo
[Música]
nuestra historia principal está en Perú
El caos que se ha vivido durante más de
un mes en las regiones del país llegó el
jueves a Lima con Seguidores del
expresidente Pedro Castillo
enfrentándose a la policía y una nube de
humo y gases lacrimógenos a pocos metros
de la Plaza de Armas donde está ubicada
la casa de Pizarro el Palacio de
Gobierno incendios explosiones tanques
del ejército en las calles uniformados y
ciudadanos heridos no hacen ceder a la
actual presidenta Dina boluarte que
reitera se mantendrá en el poder
esperando
[Música]
Paz cabina boluarte basta de reprimir al
pueblo nos estás pagando con balas a
nuestros hijos a nuestros hermanos en
este momento está ya totalmente perdido
por el fuego el gobierno está firme y su
gabinete más Unido que nunca
y el gobierno de Lima afirmó que los
disturbios dejan pérdidas por más de
200.000 dólares y los líderes de las
protestas acusan por su parte a Dina
boluarte de infiltrar vándalos entre los
manifestantes para desprestigiar el
movimiento en su contra no obstante uno
de los líderes de las protestas anunció
que los pueblos originarios quieren
independizarse en respuesta a siglos de
maltrato y olvido Estatal un nuevo
capítulo de una historia convulsa que
viene de hace varios años atrás y que
lluís Muñoz nos Explica en el siguiente
informe
cuando fue elegido ganador en primera
vuelta en las elecciones presidenciales
de Perú Pedro Castillo era un
desconocido No figuraba ni en las
encuestas fueron las cadenas de WhatsApp
del Sur del país y el hartazgo con la
clase política peruana lo que le llevó a
disputar la segunda vuelta electoral
antes de ser presidente enfrente tenía
keiko fujimori la hija del dictador por
lo que el balotaje se convirtió en una
elección entre fujimorismo y anti
fujimorismo ahí radican las claves de la
política peruana de los últimos años La
sombra del fujimorismo un congreso cuya
desaprobación en diciembre llegaba al
86% y la desconexión entre lima y el
resto del país campesino e indígena que
evidencian problemas sistémicos hay un
proceso continuo de tensiones no
resueltas hay un elemento muy fuerte de
desigualdad económica que se traduce en
términos también desigualdad social
política cultural de todo tipo de
acuerdo Entonces ellos son elementos
estructurales
y que y que hacen que el país esté
desestructurado en noviembre Pedro
Castillo pidió a la Organización de
Estados Americanos activar la carta
democrática Interamericana consideraba
que los intentos de moción de censura y
las denuncias en su contra eran una
nueva modalidad de golpe de estado una
misión de alto nivel de la oea visitó el
país e hizo un llamado al diálogo sin
embargo días después el 7 de diciembre
se convocó la tercera vacancia contra
Pedro Castillo en medio de señalamientos
en su contra por corrupción Un gobierno
esté disolvió el congreso antes de ser
destituido y después detenido acusado de
darse un autogolpe la figura de la
vacancia fue puesta en duda por la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos Perú ha tenido seis presidentes
en los últimos cuatro años con un
congreso que quita y pone a su antojo
los partidos políticos apenas tienen
militantes muchos de los justamente los
políticos más profesionales son los más
ligados a temas de corrupción a temas de
justamente de esas de esa desafección
política por lo tanto muchas veces
incluyen a personas conocidas famosas
esa corrupción llegó también a la
presidencia de los diez mandatarios
anteriores a Dina boluarte 8 han tenido
tienen causas pendientes con la justicia
por lo que el congreso pese a estar
desacreditado logra un gran poder
también en el caso de la actual
presidenta y como El Ejecutivo no tiene
bancada parlamentaria no
como no tiene fuerza política ni aparato
político está asumiendo la agenda de
política exterior del Congreso es más de
los sectores más duros del Congreso de
la derecha
madura del Congreso
tanto la oea como la cidh en su última
visita han denunciado el racismo y
clasismo que se vive en Perú con una
clase alta limeña muy lejos de un país
rural y campesino desconexión fruto de
10 años de gobierno de Alberto fujimori
etapa que se basó en desarticular al
grupo maoístas sendero luminoso
arraigado en las zonas Rurales del país
pero también en las denuncias de
crímenes de lesa humanidad
paramilitarismo y masacres por lo que
después de años sin fujimori ni sendero
luminoso la detención de Pedro Castillo
sacó la superficie problemas que durante
años tan solo se intuían
la relación entre Guatemala y Colombia
Se tornó tensa esta semana debido a que
el fiscal guatemalteco Rafael
corruchiche pidió investigar a Iván
Velásquez actual ministro de defensa de
Colombia por supuesto a corrupción
cuando dirigía la comisión internacional
contraria impunidad en Guatemala Este es
un órgano independiente que había sido
creado por la ONU Para apoyar a la
fiscalía y a las autoridades locales a
investigar delitos cometidos por otros
funcionarios y que fue desmantelada por
el expresidente de Guatemala Jimmy
Morales cuando las investigaciones de
estas ysisic llegaron a su hermano Sammy
Morales el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken informó
que curry Chiche está en la lista Engel
Este es un listado de personajes del
triángulo norte de Centroamérica que han
sido antidemocráticos o corruptos según
la Unión Americana veamos más en el
siguiente informe
tensión internacional Guatemala llevó su
persecución a Fiscales y jueces
anticorrupción a una nueva escala y se
encontró con Colombia después de que el
fiscal especial contra la impunidad
anunciase que pretendía presentar cargos
contra el ministro de defensa de
Colombia Iván Velázquez por supuesto las
acciones ilegales cuando se desempeñaba
como jefe de una misión anticorrupción
de la ONU en el país centroamericano la
fiscalía especial contra la impunidad
categóricamente manifiesta que no
escatimará esfuerzo alguno para que
quienes resulten responsables rindan
cuentas ante la justicia y paguen por
sus actos con todo el peso de la ley
Velázquez tenía inmunidad por trabajar
en la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala organismo apoyado
por la ONU no hay pruebas contundentes
en su contra tan solo mensajes donde
daba el visto bueno a negociar penas
menores a cambio de información
algo habitual en estos procesos
judiciales y además ha recibido el
absoluto respaldo de su presidente
ministros la ONU Estados Unidos y
organizaciones sociales de Colombia sí
quiero defenderemos
él seguirá siendo nuestro ministro
Guatemala insiste en apresar hombres
justos bueno tenemos que hacer
Colombia llamó a consultas al embajador
de Guatemala Mientras que el presidente
guatemalteco Alejandro yamatei llamó a
Petro a seguir la vía diplomática pero
con dardos envenenados como este voy a
dejar que el presidente Petro
siga cometiendo El error de un político
de un guerrillero de mucha tradición
pero poco político
Petro volvió a reaccionar nuestro
ministro de defensa se respeta y el
presidente se respeta
nosotros no vamos a rodear la soberanía
nacional ante una acción corrupta
entre 2013 y 2019 esta comisión de la
ONU operó en Guatemala junto a la
fiscalía destaparon diversos escándalos
que llevaron incluso a la sentencia de
16 años contra el expresidente Otto
Pérez estas investigaciones alcanzaron
en 2018 al entonces presidente Jimmy
Morales quien respondió con la expulsión
en 2018 de Iván Velázquez y terminó el
mandato de la cistic en 2019 se termina
de una vez por todas se entierra Iván
Velázquez se entierra por completo a la
sisic de nuestro sistema jurídico
guatemalteco Y si sigue Nunca más en
Guatemala el actual presidente Alejandro
yamate y continuó la persecución
iniciada por Jimmy Morales se han
terminado investigaciones contra jueces
y Fiscales sospechosos para las isig y
estas se han dirigido contra la
judicatura anticorrupción con más de 35
jueces y Fiscales en el
y con casos sonados como el de la
detención del periodista José Rubén
Zamora uno de los mayores críticos del
gobierno mientras Estados Unidos acusa a
la fiscal general Consuelo porras de
participar en hechos significativos de
corrupción
vamos a Estados Unidos para revisar la
cifra de la semana 3 Esta es la cantidad
de años que Joe biden cumple en la casa
blanca Un gobierno marcado por la
pandemia y la posterior crisis económica
ahora en el último año de su primer
mandato se abre la incógnita de su
participación en la elección de 2024
Rodrigo cedano tiene los detalles
así juramento Joe biden como el
presidente número 46 de Estados Unidos
con fuertes medidas de seguridad tras la
toma del Capitolio unos días antes en su
primer día una premisa revertir las
políticas más dañinas de la era trampa
vamos a combatir el cambio climático de
una forma que nunca antes hicimos
también vamos a reconstruir nuestra
economía esta serían las claves de su
primer año vacunación masiva contra el
covid-19 vuelta a los acuerdos
climáticos de París y un proyecto de
inversión Estatal para relanzar la
economía a largo plazo una tenía marcada
en estos dos años por la alta inflación
que apenas ahora comienza a descender
por contra vaiden no hizo realidad sus
promesas de revertir las peores
políticas migratorias de Trump sigue en
pie el título 42 que se cobija en la
emergencia sanitaria por la pandemia
para expulsar rápidamente a migrantes
indocumentados en su segundo año de
mandato firmó una orden ejecutiva para
intentar proteger el acceso al aborto
luego que la Corte Suprema anulara el
histórico fallo Rover versus wait que
amparaba la interrupción del embarazo
no podemos permitir a una Corte Suprema
fuera de control que trabaje con los
elementos más extremistas del partido
republicano esto no detuvo una ola de
prohibiciones en los Estados
republicanos en el terreno político
consiguió sorpresivamente minimizar la
victoria republicana en las elecciones
de medio término los demócratas
perdieron la cámara de representantes
pero mantuvieron el senado los
republicanos digamos desplegarán todo su
artillería pero también hay que ver que
el presidente tiene a los demócratas de
su lado en el senado y que también el
derecho del del veto vayan ha impulsado
el gasto millonario en ayuda militar a
Ucrania que ha fortalecido su liderazgo
internacional pero entra en su tercer
año de mandato lidiando con la polémica
por los papeles clasificados encontrados
en su residencia sobre los que avisaron
sus propios abogados un caso por el que
los republicanos abrirán comités de
investigación en la cámara de
representantes
encontramos que un puñado de documentos
estaban archivados en el lugar
equivocado inmediatamente los entregamos
al departamento de Justicia para que se
resuelva rápidamente
el mandatario ya anunció su intención de
optar a la reelección en 2024 la
pregunta es si a su avanzada edad
aguantará una nueva carrera presidencial
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América Sigan viendo France 24
[Música]